it's a long and torturous road back home
for these Venezuelan migrants hundreds
are trying to make the 556 kilometer
long journey to Colombia's border with
Venezuela on foot fleeing not just the
cove in nineteen epidemic but acute
unemployment that is obliging them to
return home Agata Poisson with the
situation that is happening with
coronavirus things have changed people
don't treat us the same it's not
possible to go out to sell because there
are no more people on the street because
of the situation Venezuelans are also
returning to the border with Brazil with
a pandemic is spreading poverty as well
as disease in the back of this market in
Rio de Janeiro people who've been left
unemployed by the crisis queue for
leftover fish and vegetables I won't buy
the day and I've been without work for
two weeks I have five children at home
I'm afraid of the coronavirus but I'm
also afraid my children will have
nothing to eat so like it or not I have
to go out the need for people to stay
isolated is wreaking havoc in Latin
America's largest economy
this woman warns that soon food handouts
will not be enough if this continues
everyone is going to be dying of hunger
is going to be a war people are going to
want to invade the markets and unlike
the Venezuelans millions of Brazilians
who are now out of work and out of money
have nowhere else to go
Lucia Neumann al-jazeera